hi YouTube well that was fast at the end
of January I made a video thanking the
first 100,000 subscribers for joining my
channel and now just three months later
the subscribers have been doubled which
is an unbelievable rate of growth so
thank you so much to everyone who's
joined up with me on this little corner
of the Internet these last three months
have been a crazy busy time for me with
too many projects going on at once and
the next three months will probably be
the same with more videos and other
stuff on the way but one project that's
finished now thanks to Hank green a man
who himself runs so many different
things it's hard to keep track of them
all is the CGP grey shirt which is now
available on the dftba store in case
you're wondering the proceeds of the
shirt will be used to purchase coffee
that coffee will fuel the typing and
clicking needed to manufacture videos
videos which may contain links to buy
the very shirts that brought them into
existence thus completing the circle of
life so go grab one today if you'd like
to support the channel
it's been amazing making videos for you
when watching the channel grow they're
now releasing each video to so many
people is slightly intimidating even
though I take far far too long
researching each one I still spend the
first few minutes after uploading living
in fear that I've made some
unintentional error and waiting for the
inevitable comment pointing out where
I've made a typo and there are always
typos but terror of errors aside the
nice thing about having such a large
community is being able to share not
only my own stuff with you but also
other people's videos either through
hidden links on my own or in separate
playlists like the one I've made this
week though on these videos I've noticed
people often leave comments like Grey's
army coming through and I'm not sure
that an army is the best representation
of who we are a more Science and
Technology guy who likes reason and
simple things that turn complex and
interesting ways and since you're here
watching these videos I assume you are
as well I'm not sure what the best
collective noun for this growing
community is but if you have any
thoughts I'd love to hear them anyway
I'm getting off topic you are the reason
I can continue to make these videos
thank you for watching and thank you for
subscribing